j'étais au Club Med de ma naissance à
maintenant m'appelle trident
[Musique]
du Club Med
tu pourrais quand même accueillir à ton
petit frère demi-frère encore mieux je
prends moins de place je veux retrouver
mon amour d'enfance de mes 8 ans
violette je peux dormir ici alors oui je
savais je le savais ça
depuis 8 ans toi non plus tu as vu ta
gueule
[Musique]
vous retrouverez c'est une erreur que sa
ville est là-bas déjà tu t'appelles plus
Roxane tu t'appelles violette ok je
m'appelle violette voilà
non tu t'appelles violette oui ok
j'ai l'impression d'être dans un film
d'espionnage j'adore sexy heureuse
[Musique]
j'ai une grande nouvelle pour toi parce
que j'ai retrouvé
[Musique]
ça fait si longtemps
oui pardon c'est l'émotion de le revoir
[Musique]